i have some incredible video for you
today it would be funny if it weren't so
scary
cnn's jim acosta while the nra
convention was happening in houston
texas in the same state were 72 hours
earlier we had this horrific shooting in
uvalde texas cnn's jim acosta
interviewed a board member of the
national rifle association that board
member is a republican judge named
phillip journey
also a former kansas state senator
uh jim acosta asked why should an 18
year old be able to have an ar-15 why
does an 18 year old need an ar-15
and again it would be hilarious if it
weren't for the fact that these people
and this organization were so powerful
take a look at this historic implosion
on live television
with these mass shootings it keeps
coming back to the it keeps coming back
to the ar-15 and similar models
why do people need an ar-15 anyway
you know it's just a semi-automatic
rifle i mean you know if you want to be
prejudiced about the way it looks but i
was aware of what happened in the 94
semi-automatic firearms ban and there
were rifles of similar function that
just didn't look as ugly they weren't
black guns like a mini 14 ruger mini 14.
so i i i can't help but mention
this talking point about there's
prejudice against certain prejudice
against certain weapons based on how
they look
they want to almost make it like it's a
form of racism like you're judging
things by their cover and that you're
you're prejudiced if you look at a
weapon and say that's a bad weapon
they want to use the same terms almost
as if it were a form of racism this is a
concerted effort that they make to talk
about prejudice and discrimination
against firearms based on the way they
look okay let's continue the meaningless
word salad and of course the ruger mini
14 was appropriate and the ar-15 was not
if it had a bayonet lug or a vertical
rear grip
so they designed i do want to ask you
about the assault weapons man but you
know on the ar-15
how how is it that an 18-year-old can
buy an ar-15 style rifle and have 1600
rounds of ammo with him like we saw in
uvalde
well it's he did not have any prior
convictions he didn't have any prior
issues that would have kept him from
purchasing one it's my understanding
from the news that he purchased it
through a firearms dealer he passed a
background check because he didn't have
any prior convictions now of course this
is the problem if we did the things i
suggested
limit these firearms to those 25 plus
um
require more extensive training require
two or three letters from adults in the
community saying i have no issues with
this individual having firearms require
a mental health evaluation
those things
would likely have at least made it more
difficult for these for this individual
to get these particular firearms what
this guy's saying is
he got him because there was nothing in
place that stopped him right well but
that's the problem we need to put things
in place
right but should an 18 year old have an
ar-15 he bought it should an a should an
18 year old have an ar-15
what's he going to do i don't know an 18
year old have one in the army
so they had military they had military
training in the army this 18 year old in
uvalde did not have military training he
turned 18 and he went out bought an
ar-15
okay
and the fact is that these kinds of
issues did you just call them ed
are far more complicated than whether we
remove something from the public
these issues in criminogenics can't buy
a beer if you're 18. you can't buy
packages on crime are more complicated
than than the easy answer
do you want to know why politicians
seems to go to gun control because it
doesn't cost them any money oh god uh
okay so listen completely humiliating i
mean a complete and total implosion that
being said the pro-gun people do have an
easy answer which this guy just missed i
don't agree with this answer but
sometimes you know when when you ask
some of these folks this exact question
that jim acosta is asking sometimes they
go
jim i don't need to defend it it's in
the constitution period now it's lame it
ignores reality but it is an answer
which is like just because you don't
like it jim doesn't mean it isn't in the
constitution it's not about why does an
18 year old need it we have a
constitution and a right to bear arms
now of course the counter would be
limiting certain guns for certain people
whether because of age or whatever these
are not violations of the second
amendment
um so there is uh there are rebuttals to
the rebuttals for sure and this entire
thing of your prejudice against guns
because of how they look they want you
to think like it's racism now one bonus
here as you all may know and we will
look at later
donald trump danced he did his dance on
stage after speaking to the nra three
days after the horrible shooting in
texas
jim acosta asked this guy this nra board
member
about trump's dancing and the guy just
denies that it happened and then cnn
puts it up on the screen alongside this
guy saying trump didn't dance and this
is what we've been talking about for a
long time
it doesn't matter if it's on video
they'll still deny stuff and yuvaldi
your group is holding its convention in
houston where you are right now just a
few days after the massacre and yuvaldi
we saw donald trump dancing on stage uh
at the end of his remarks uh he was not
i was there he was not dancing how was
it how is any of this how is any of this
at all appropriate we're showing it on
stage right now he's doing a little jig
there
people are waving their nra hats and so
on it's this celebratory
atmosphere right after a mass shooting
where all of these kids are gunned down
how is that appropriate
i think that what you're doing is just
telling part of the story there because
at the beginning of his speech he did do
a very memorable memorial for the victim
so first he says trump didn't dance and
then when the video gets put on the
screen he says well the dancing is only
part of the story but but you just said
he didn't dance so which is it these
people are really sick really really
sick they are not a scourge as trump
pronounces it but they're they're really
a scourge
and uh we're going to look at what
happened at the nra convention after the
break but we've got an uphill battle
here my friends i do want to announce we
are going to be doing our next david
pakman show member town hall on june
14th at 6 p.m eastern it'll be streamed
on the pacman live youtube channel only
and i hope you'll join me there
one of our sponsors is toodaloo the
plant-based trail mix that's delicious
and climate conscious it's hard for me
to pick my favorite thing about toodaloo
the sweet and savory flavors are great
toodaloo regenerates 100 square feet of
polluted farmland with every purchase
and gives to causes that are fighting
plastic pollution
every bag has 35 grams of plant-based
proteins there's no refined oil or
processed sugars or artificial flavors
the stuff i try to avoid it's not in
there you can pronounce all of the
ingredients i've been snacking on
toodaloo regularly at home while i'm
working my favorite flavor is the spicy
citrus raw nuts pumpkin and flour seeds
apple pineapple chickpeas with a spicy
lemon lime kick you can also get
barbecue chocolate clusters coffee one
of my favorites is maple brittle listen
guys my roots are in new england of
course maple it's delicious no
ingredients to feel guilty about it's
just a great snack and it's a company
that's doing good things for the planet
and they support our show so go to
toodaloo.com
pacman use the code pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below